gang all tickets are on sale right now
for the 2024 through the roof tour over
there at rug garbage.com
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of a
you garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it if
they're grw up to be classy yeah or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash trash trash I'm your host St Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at toies in the new
edition she's uh she's out and about
okay doing her thing all right if
anybody comes by and asks she's away for
a couple of weeks all right cops are
looking for her okay what are you going
to do keep your story straight keep your
story keep your mouth shut is what she
said when she left the house keep your
fat ass mouth shut I believe is the way
she phrased it okay it's a little rude
bit of a dude on her that toy mike ho is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of ouru garbage he is an
international businessman dress like a
cat burglar give it up for KJ Kevin J
Ryan what up gang what's going on pork
chop uh not much thanks for tuning in
gang as always please make sure you R
you subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are TR cing and obviously the
greatest website of all time you pull
out your little computer little desktop
your little application and go to
www.patreon.com you garbage go over
there and join the [__] Army of
garbage with over 13,000 members on that
godstorm patreon baby 13,000 strong and
a bajillion hours of content that's a
regimen or a Alan or something uhhuh
it's a lot it's a lot of people I know
that much take Normandy with that sure I
mean I don't want to Hey listen let him
know it's back
on I got ties to Eastern European
Eastern German television find out where
your loyalties Li sure check you for
wires uh and also before I before I
forget the through the roof tour is on
sale now baby our biggest tour today
some of the biggest venues we've ever
played get those tickets at rug
garbage.com gang Town Hall New York City
The Wilbur and Boston mhm funny bones I
know couple couple of clubs couple of
funny Bel love a funny bone let's go
shout out to a nice comedy club in a
mall I'm talking to you Albany and
Syracuse yeah come out and see the boy
haven't been there in a minute I know
I'm looking forward to go back guys if
you've seen the shows before if you come
to a live show you know they're a good
time grab the homies grab your friends
come on out and let's pack these [__]
places out Kang yeah let's pack them out
baby everything at rug garbage.com and
there's probably still a couple of the
card games left but they are dwindling
so don't be hitting us up when they're
gone is that a marketing tactic cuz
they're
not only two left act now I got 12 cases
behind me Meanwhile we're going to be
pushing them again in a week hey they're
getting really low now gang how a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works to ones twos threes
fours crosses te's dots eyes he cashes
checks and he likes to break necks give
it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullan everybody what up dude dog dog
on the way here I had a nice little
giggle at Two Fellas on the sidewalk
uhhuh uh one guy's eating a dut the guy
goes ah look good just me and fley fine
the other guy's bald smoking a cigarette
spying on us that was a gluten-free
donut by the way that was a cronut oh
love a cronut mhm this was a very fancy
donut this gentleman was eating okay and
he goes oh this new place is great all
types of donuts coconut and I saw his
buddy hit him with an eye roll that
would have stopped a train it was like
watching a friendship end I know
Coconut's all right though no what get
out of here Dunkin Donuts used to do a
coconut I believe I don't know they used
to be in the operative phid it was a
cake donut and it was uh like cooking it
all around it I'm not a donut guy give
me a you give me give me a classic an
oldfashioned whatever but like I ain't
doing all at you know maybe yeah no not
for me I'm a bagel man I like a coconut
give me a bacon egg and cheese what are
we doing this breakfast it ain't dessert
[__] get me some scrambies a bacon an
omelette something what the [__] a
donut doing for me can do you have that
lighter on you don't make fun of me I
just want to see it uh I just want to
look at it again sure go go outside of
the back porch you know you know what's
very trashy I have multiple lighters on
me rolling around no you always steal my
lighters bad no this is uh this is crazy
hey no you can't make fun of it first of
all it's a skankfest lighter there you
go ah I don't know how this ended up in
my pocket as of recent I must have uh
stole it from somebody but it's got a
bottle opener on it yeah that's the
thing that they're tough anytime it's a
it's a functional that's tough that's
like the flipflops with the bottle
opener on them shout out to skankfest
baby yeah shout out to it yeah um but
that is the trashest that's tough I
don't think I've ever really used one
yeah that style that's the one you take
off and the cter get the high flame
should I do that no I think I should no
I don't know I don't know if toty PID
your insurance should rig the lighter I
haven't done it in a long time you think
you still got what it takes uh I think
so right you just do that and you lift
it up you slide it over o I think I got
it feel the teeth caught on that one oh
you gotta do a couple more times than
that
bro damn that ain't no CGI either gang
that's real pyrot Technics I feel like
Elon Musk dude hit him with it be
careful you're good
man you ever get caught with one of
those somebody does that to you or like
cranks it all the way up you burn an
eyebrow yeah I started a wildfire with
my eyebrows [__] those things went up
yeah no that's bad yeah you Rigg the
lighter on somebody and then they you
know that was a big thing I was a
lighter kid growing up I always had a li
I thought you were pretty
heavy
meatball I I collected lighters light
second dinner maybe uh no that wasn't
either going down and hitting that reron
that was still in the
pan once oh baby it would congeal it'd
be it'd be like a loaf yeah um no I
would uh I always had lighters so we
would always be we would always be
rigging them I would take them from my
dad I had Zippos at a young age I had a
couple of gun lighters I would get on
the Wildwoods board man I had one it was
a revolver like a little snubnose and it
I actually still have it it would turn
like the the the barrel or whatever you
call it would turn with it like man pop
out of cops now [__] holding people
up with that thing on the board give me
your tokens give me all your give me all
your tickets to EDS fun C give me all
your bubble taper I'll give you um yeah
that got me thinking somebody hit me the
other day uh um with uh this little
snubnose Bick I sent you I sent you a
thing of it it's crazy this thing is
nuts oh I love those things that's crazy
they should be in the house for c yeah
it says perfect for candles and more
they're great for candles and if you're
that's for light and light bulbs what
are you talking about dude if you're
catching a heater at the house that's
great that's a that's like a that's like
a mini grill lighter I'd rather have a
grill lighter that thing is that that
coming out of somebody's pocket talk
about looking like a gun dude my buddy
Matt in high school would hit you with
the grill lighter like he had it in the
car and it would be in his pockets he
I'm like Jesus put that thing away
you're going to get us hit you're going
to get knocked the only thing about the
grill lighter I love those lighters Hey
listen it goes mini bits that's classy
to me it goes mini mini bxs is the the
the cream of the crop it's small it fits
in the pocket no big bck no they're too
big you're out of the heater game and
you've been for a minute you're wrong
may maybe when you were smoking bowls at
some
yeah little bick hippie Festival the
little bck is an adults lighter that's
what that is yeah it's an adult lighter
I'm a kid heart that's true he's got a
he's got a youthful youthful vibe to
them then it goes big bck then it goes
those things th those we call them
crackhead lighters growing up they were
crackhead lighters those 99 Cents or
whatever and then it would go the grill
lighter I you're missing a key lighter
that be often forgotten about the
cylinder my favorite the Clipper the
Clipper what's the Clipper yeah that's
great those are
with the little back little flap on it
and the the Flint part pops out so you
can pack joints and stuff excellent n
times out of 10 that lighter says Myrtle
Beach somewhere on it sure yeah that's a
very big chachki lighter that's the
number one lighter in the UK that's
their bck no way really yes man I'm also
Wy over there they they always got to
make a stand don't they they were they
dried in a side a different side of the
road got cool lighters fish and chips um
you be kidding me those things stink
they don't fit in your pocket
no they do they wobble around my Aunt
Kathy was big on having she always had
like next Generation lighters she had it
for like a couple of days it would have
like a tassel on it or something like
that I she was the first person to break
one of those out in front of me I was a
big uh I mean we I think we've said it
before but the the Jeeps I don't even
know if that's how it's pronounced those
things are awesome the big they're like
disposable lighter Zippos kind of it was
d j p oh those little fat ones oh you
get one of them baby talk about for the
serious
smoker Jesus Christ yeah that's for a
guy who's got his [__] together yeah
somebody needs a chest x-ray yeah that
that guy don't need a cosigner on an
apartment I they started up marro was
they the marro ones were banging with
them for a long time so we would have
those would be floating around a lot I
forgot or or Winston's like Winston
NASCAR had them too they were the big de
jeeps and then they used to have a
little safety on the back where you
click it in and then man any little
baby's fingers could light those things
dude those were not child those were
easy lighting for kids that grow up
quick uhhuh yeah did you ever see these
things I think it's like a
taser oh the butane lighters yeah yeah
oh that's electric yeah that's not the
butane lighters got my an alien get out
of here that's not what to go GLE gorp
no way dude they're crazy Tatooine weed
or something like that you're smoking he
can't be doing that now classic regular
lighter with a nice glass of Vulcan
ale we're doing space sci-fi bits over
here kid where you at do you know what a
Vulcan is no you don't know what a
Vulcan is huh all right should I this
mean anything to you Spock was a Vulcan
hit me baby I figured it was some sort
of breed of
alien some kind of superhuman mutant or
something I don't know he was superhuman
sure I wonder that how Spock could hand
he wasn't superum he was an alien no he
was tough though spot could mess you up
he was strong super human means you're a
super human all right all right now
you're just splitting hairs with me all
right it's
ridiculous I mean I don't know what to
tell you that's a real klling on
move anyway yeah somebody handed me that
lighter and I was like dude what the
hell uh this doesn't fit right no you're
not wrong you're not wrong for sure uh
but all that being said we got a gosh
Dar Family episode gang we got to get
into it as you know when you join a
patreon one of the you know what you
join one of the 13,000 that's FS a
stadium that's crazy 13 a small Regional
Stadium sure it's the Trenton Thunder
that's the way we like it yeah I was
driving by the Trent and thunder I would
love to go to a [__] minor league
ball game minor league baseball game
yeah yeah they were all right do a
little scouting yeah the box score I'm
sure you get you know decent deal on
some big beers probably a good soft
pretzel plus you catch a guy rehabbing
sure getting off the junk [__] Lenny
dyster or something down there pitching
somebody down there working uhhuh
yeah um but I'd be down you got the con
Island you got Cone Island out there too
I'd rather Cone Island seems like it
takes a hundred years to get to I drove
out there one time to look at a couch a
chair that we were going to buy off
Craigslist wow oh my God things are
going well this this was a dude and we
got out there and it was white my wife's
like yeah I'm like B they showed like
the actual I think it was Ikea or
something like they showed the actual
picture from ik that's not the real one
and my wife was like I think it's going
to be in pretty good shape I'm like no D
it was it was in a cell phone store on
Cony Island and we had to go into I'm
like I ain't [__] going we a the
previous owner used to guess weights on
the boardwalk yeah it was it was dicey
went you get the body out of it it's all
yours yeah dead cat laying in it it was
rough no thanks she was like I can't
believe they wouldn't post a real
picture I'm like Lady this is New York
City everybody's trying to rob you here
that damn H Seed I know what are you
doing go back to that Village should be
wearing wooden
shoes
uh uh but as you know when you join a
patreon over there we will answer your
garbage question on the air uh all right
this one's from C Willie uh $10 homie
never had one read is a garbage to wear
a Hard Rock Cafe t-shirt from a city
you've never been to Hard Rock Cafe
shirt anytime anywhere trash unless you
are a dime piece hot chicks can pull
that off hot chicks can pull anything
off so that's that's you know I you
can't really you can't really grade on
that curve yeah any Hard Rock Cafe
t-shirt Planet Hollywood was a real
tough one for me I think n the planet
Hollywood's a little more vintage which
I don't understand they cool no for a
minute I thought you had to be in the
movie industry to get a table there I
swear I thought it was all cuz you
always just saw like Schwartz and Egger
and Stallone at the planet high they
were opening them up yeah I didn't know
I just figured you had to be an A-list
celeb can I ask you this what is a Hard
Rock Cafe it's like a a music venue
right yeah it's it's similar to a
Rainforest Cafe and that it's a themed
restaurant they're in their melting
faces [__] whammy and all that [__] I
know they have there's a Hard Rock
casino right they have their own casinos
I think hard rock yeah I think hard rock
hard rock yeah get get the history on
Hard Rock Cafe it probably started as a
music venue that like it's like an
Applebees and blues place I got you all
right makes performed it one yeah me too
in Philly down in Philly uhhuh huh yeah
1971 I see the play here so big UPS to
Hard Rock C Hard Rock Cafe Hard Rock
Cafe is a chain themed bar restaurant
memorabilia shop casino and museums
where was it founded man you throw a CVS
in there you're all set where was it
founded talk about covering the bases
London isn't it really I knew that was
just cramming in it I would have said La
I pictured La too like next to the Viper
Room so places like this what makes a
genius is that because they are a quote
unquote Museum it's a tax right off damn
we got to turn this place into a museum
get some memorability the world's
fattest man ladies and gentlemen Step Up
step in one in wins any prize any no but
if we if we can get like fonzi's jacket
or something like that start hanging on
bar clothes what do you were celebrities
I remember when we went in certain
markets listen you go to Rochester and
you ask them if they want my D ear in
hard hat they'll be slipping out of
their
seats this guy can't walk down the
street and Kansas City um Canton Ohio I
remember uh when we went to when we did
the the Foley family pilgrimage down the
DC one hot summer day January
6th one hot summer day uhhuh um we went
over there to the Natural History Museum
you know we saw the memorials and all
that stuff went to the Natural History
Museum made a beine for the film and
television area yeah didn't want to see
like the space shuttle or anything like
that uhh straight to straight to Archie
Bunker's chair I remember my dad sitting
there looking at that thing like it was
like it was sure like was a guy shrouded
tur or whatever it'sh dude just like you
believe that that's the chair and that
F's jacket and I remember radar
O'Reilly's hat was in there from Mash
you know who you know who that is radar
O'Reilly vaguely yes yeah mhm sitting
there looking at that that's what we
need some some of that stuff in here I'm
in if it I mean if we can write this say
that's the the knights original what not
even that's a it's King Arthur's that is
arth hey R we if we if we can jam
something in the side Jesus Christ wore
that thing he was a knight
probably but I'll say this hard rock
does real good with the with the merch
yeah it's a brand I mean I I would argue
most people probably know it's a plate
like a hard rock that's just like a
brand at this point you know what I mean
wonder what the Grub's like over there
probably pretty [__] good like a
Margaritaville it's like casual dining
yeah it's like it's like an apple or
it's like a tji Fridays with like live
music probably know a sampler straighten
your right up yeah let's hit the great
Burgers there you go you know where I
went to there was the oh how do you feel
about the onion ring in the burger don't
love it don't love an onion ring me
either I wish they were a little
crispier if it was up to me never really
met one that I fell in love with onion
strips you know what I mean they a
little less like cuz then need just bite
it the onion comes out and you got a
bunch of bread which hey I like bread
but I don't want the [__] I feel like
I'm eating a slug Burger King's onion
rings stink there's not even onion in it
it's just like onion flavored uh
breading goop I'd be all right with that
oh I don't like the goop nah lose me on
the goop they used to be hot back in the
day I feel like there were onions in
them back in the day they're almost like
Hush Puppies they're like ring Hush
Puppies I remember them being little
tiny microscopic diced onions and this
is this is this this is a little
Sidetrack but just the onion ring shape
those Peach ringss those can kick rocks
too you know what I'm talking about you
think about food in shape versions sure
okay uh the same thing sure you know
what I'm talking about the peach rings
they're good every now and then ah get
out of here with that you know what I do
like the frogs or the Sharks oh come on
now man that little white belly on them
that's all right Ki ke what's talk about
blue I'm hard right now talking all you
soft ones out
there you limp noodles let's go me boys
gang if not getting it up is getting you
stressed out do yourself a favor get
over to Blue chew they're an online
service that sends chewable tablets
right to your door that have the same
active ingredient as Viagra seis and
Levitra oh baby you can take them any
time day or night so you're always ready
to go I take one drop it in my diet coke
Shake It Up good night hello Irene if
you catch my Dr walk by this guy
everything's done online there's no
awkward doctor visits are waiting in
line Forever at the pharmacy everything
is easily shipped right to you in
discreet packaging so the neighbors
don't gotta know you gotta limp nudes uh
bluechew bottom line gang here is the
turkey blue soy milk blue wants you to
have better sex or just if you want to
have a good time [__] masturbating
whatever you want to do discover your
options at Blue J listen not everybody's
got a partner you know what I mean
sometimes you got to get a job done
yourself catch it yourself uh discover
your options at bluechew.com chew it and
do it or masturbate and we and we've got
a special deal for are you garbage
listers try try blue Chu for free when
you use code garbage at checkout just
pay $5 shipping that's blue.com promo
code garbage to receive your first month
for free visit blu.com for more details
important safety information and thank
you blue Chu for sponsoring the Pod yes
okay looks like about DraftKings shout
out to the kings of the draft Yeah the
king of the sports book draft King
sports book gang new customers can bet
on the big game and turn five bucks into
200 instantly in bonus bets how about
that that ain't bad baby talk about
spicing up the big game Let's Go Let it
Ride put a little turkey on a Super Bowl
58 uh Super Bowl is already exciting and
you know that I know that but betting
with draftking adds a whole new level of
fun to the game download uh the
draftking Sportsbook app now and use the
code ay new customers can bet $5 to get
200 instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking sports book an official sports
betting partner of the super Bowl 58
with code a y the crown is yours from
one king to another got a gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or in West
Virginia visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net if you're in New
York call
8778 Hope n or text hopen 467
369 in Connecticut are you out there
help is available for problems with
gambling call
9777 77 or visit ccpg dog please play
responsibly on behalf of booill Casino
and Resort in Kansas 21 plus age varies
by jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus
bets expire 168 hours after issuance cdk
ng.com for eligibility and deposit
restriction terms and responsible gaming
resources I nailed that do it yeah uh I
you know what I hit recently that was
not that great I could have just had a
bad table there was a big group of us
Red Robin no kidding supposed to be
known for the they have like a bajillion
Burgers never been in one it was all
right like Ruby Tuesdays yeah but I
think like a even a lower rent Ruby
Tuesday whose wedding was this uh it was
[Music]
after I think it was I went to I think
we I think it was the anniversary of my
stepdad's death that's where he was went
I think so after the cemetery no well we
did the
cemetery and then uh oh no and then we
took the kids out to you know as like a
thing we did Top Golf I told you let
playing the
Tombstones play hide the flowers and
then um stealing pennies off of the uh
uh there you go all right uh and then uh
we went to Top Golf that was more just
for the kids just so happen to be the
same day a trashy afternoon I and then
Top Golf and Red Robin uhhuh
all right couple keyline pie sh wrong
with that you said it's stunk yeah but
it's a good oldfashioned fun right there
what's wrong with [__] top go which
we got to do by the way I want to do it
so bad what's wrong with that what did
they do steak fries over there at Red
Robin I forget to be honest with you
coming a basket uh it was like they hit
you with a bunch of like do you want the
Mondo Burger there was too many options
and they weren't there were I was like
go see if you get a menu the the the
burgers are all like they were just
making fun of you where you want the big
you want the big head Burger I'm like
what's that no was like we have the t
two helmet Burgers
please yeah I guess they do have the
steak fries they have a whole bottomless
section that's bottomless hold on a
second yeah and they give you they give
you not enough a little bit like they
don't even fill the plate at least they
didn't for me which was a little
disappointing as my first run huh go to
the burgers the burgers second it was
like it was like
uh I think I might have done the Whiskey
River BBQ if I remember correctly which
has the onions Twizzlers on it Twizzlers
strips yeah I'll give you
that it just wasn't great The Whiskey
River man but they have like a bajillion
Burgers they were all kind of the same
thing it wasn't great wasn't great I got
to give I got to put another set of eyes
on it h the beers were cold I like they
got pizza too you it's through
donad
don't ask me how I know that true you
got a steak in the there's certain
Italian names that in a Philly accent
sounds so trashy dados one of them ELO
over to ELO shout out to Aldo we went to
jeppi I used to work at jeppis I know
you did made that fat broad slip and
then I saw her to Burger King years
later dumb [__] should have never
yelled at me in the [__] dining room
you get what you get now you're [__]
shelling out onion rings [__] put no
onions in them [__] [__] anyway
great question about the Hard Rock T
yeah fantastic I remember one time I
never like everybody rocks them I just
could never pull it off but they weren't
cool when I was a like you were that was
like nerdy if you were rocking that now
they're cool unless Pamela Anderson
sleeves cut off out yeah and that's even
like ironic that she's W like if I wor
it looked like I was like check me out I
was just at the Hard Rock I want to say
it was a souvenir and that wasn't cool
if memory serves me correct you're
talking 89 90 maybe
91 Planet Fitness or not Planet Fitness
Planet Hollywood fre did not his pizza
on Friday Planet Hollywood Hard Rock
leather jackets were being worn
unironically and they were cool that was
also the time when if you had a Jeep and
you had a um uh yosity Sam on the back
shooting Six Guns you were cool too that
stuff the shelf life on that went real
quick where that became real cheesy yeah
it was when Millie Vanilli got busted
things really started going sou sure you
know uhhuh that's when the wool was
really pulled back yeah everybody
started waking up it's all a
lie that's a heartbreaker my dad love
Millie vanell really what I I mean I
don't think anybody disliked them Millie
vilon for some reason he loved
UB40 what the hell's UB 40 red red red
red red wine UB 47 dude what are you
talking about I'd be 48 oh red red wine
all right oh that's a hit it's a c cover
too I think mhm they were great anyway I
digress all right let's see uh this
one's from Brandon Hayes $10 homie never
had one red are you garbage if you
freeze leftovers from a restaurant ooh
you can't do that [__] that's got a Max
36-h hour shelf life on it that's din
that's lunch or dinner the next day and
I would say even that's kind of anything
after that dinner's super pushing it I
just saw a thing the other day where
people freeze dried stuff they made soup
and they they have like it looks like um
like an oven but you have to put it in a
tray yeah yeah yeah freeze dryer or like
instant freezer type thing yeah
yeah I had like that I had a buddy who
on Chipotle free burrito day went to
like 10 different Chipotle I kind of
respect this got the burritos froze them
and ate them for like a month I kind of
respect that how eat them up without
them like burning you put it in the
microwave oven or the oven yeah you know
I wasn't handson with the R&D Department
also this guy's probably eating cold
burritos what are we talking about
burrito sickle yeah he's I don't hate
that this guy's not bring you know he's
yeah cuz you know we don't bring up cuz
you I think I think you little Whipper
Snappers are way too young but do you
remember the frozen burritos at like
7-Eleven and stuff like that oh they
used have the best 7-Eleven it was just
mush du bomb with the nacho cheese best
microwave burrito of all time they
discontinued it El Paso made them or
something I feel like was still doing
them in New York at that BP that I used
to live next to really they sold them in
well like I we didn't have any cookware
in the apartment I was living in and we
would [__] we would get them there
for like two bucks I used to my dude if
I I I I was thinking about the other day
my diet when I first moved up here 90%
of the food came from a BP a good gas
station order I'm guessing well there
was a Dunkin' Donuts in the BP so
breakfast was the bacon egg and cheese
or sausage egg and cheese with the tots
and and that 99 the 99 cent big Arizona
Iced Tea like that was every day I would
I would have that and I would eat it in
my car like a fat straight up Arizona
yeah oh the can the big can whoa every
day every day one of those that was just
for breakfast I've had in Arizona for
breakfast and you feel real bad about
yourself then I would also get an extra
uh I'd get an extra large extra extra so
extra cream extra sugar I didn't know I
heard some guy order one time and
thought it was cool so I that's what I
started doing so much I'll do an extra
large extra
extra I'm surprised my feet are still on
dude I did that for every day for and
then at lunch I would walk to go get
pizza and I would do uh they would do
like chicken fingers cut up like a
chicken cutlet on a pizza I do one slice
of that and one slice of pepperoni and a
20 oz coat PA of Pepsi let's go and then
that was was dude that's by 1100 a.m.
then I'm [__] then we go out and do
[__] comedy and whatever that was I'm
sure that more pizza and IC I'm sure
that order at BP in the afternoons
definitely included one of those 99 cent
sleeves of peanuts whether it be
planners well that was when I started
watching my figure but before that I
found these those are all right I found
those little and you've seen them they
have really bad packaging and they're
always in like shitty bodegas or gas
stations they're red and yellow no
they're not peanuts the they're like the
they're called like
country they're like granola bars and
there's like a blue and white package
one a gray and white package there's
like a peanut one a chocolate chip one
they're kind of like I know Grandma's
cookies in a pinch at a bodega they're
all right oh yeah you know what I'm
talking about oh yeah woo that old broad
knew what she was doing with a double
fudge chocolate cookie I'll tell you
that right now let's go uh delicious
always
moist and whatever they were once I
found them man that was a [__] wrap
for me I would do I thought they were
Health Foods they were just candy bar
they were cheap candy bars like a Kudos
very similar to a Kudos uh I think it's
these Sun Bel Bakery oh I know exactly
what you're talking about this let's
see I know exactly what you're talking
about Sun Belt they were like 50 cents
yeah yeah these mhm they were like0 50
cents they're at the checkout and I
would just grab like five of them and
just [__] mush them with a root beer
or something dude those deals used to be
crazy you get the the strip of powdered
little mini Donuts 50 Cent anything
Little Debbie or Drakes I remember going
into the the bodega below our apartment
on uh Second Avenue with like
$3.50 in Chains and coming out with a
meal with couple bags of party mix and
peanuts something sweet little sweet
treat and an Arizona those arizonas man
the great byy that's what they were
called they were called the great but
man they I they [__] talk about
keeping the country going let's go are
they can you see if they're still 99 c
yeah they're still 99 C but then some of
the bodegas and [__] start charging like
a125 even though it says 99 cents on the
[__] can you better not let that
owner find out that guy's adamant about
keeping that price point adamant the 99
Cents oh yeah they got to be responsible
for most of diabetes I don't think so
why get people through their work day
they did the green tea for a little
while see how honey and Jin sing that
was the first time any of us had Jin
sing if it wasn't for Arizona I never
had we wouldn't know about jining never
had that that was the hot chick drink
yeah that's why I wasn't drinking it I
was [__] shotgunning the heavy bike
Joan me Arnold Palmer shut up 99 Cents
baby course come on and then I switched
over to the aror aror Palmer for sure
gentleman's drink uh-huh I would buy
those at a luk oil on Street Road when I
was working for my family and I would
eat two soft pretzels and a thing of
combo and Crush one of them that was my
that was like my 1030 thing it's like
insulin Memory Lane here I like it man
doing it strolling back that piece of
shits uh all right let's see here this
one's from reys um hold on there ate a
better combo than lemonade nice day
up get that tang in the back of your
mouth then my mom this was probably like
right out of college I was like living
at home and like kind of before I moved
out she would buy and she still might or
for years she would buy that big jug of
the Arnold Palmer that's crazy that
always settled we at the bottom it
looked like bad pain you shake it up
didn't it never fully shook I shake up
everything I shake milk I shake orange
juice anything but soda I'm giving it a
shake before I drink it probably way I
have heartburn all the time full of
bubbles guys guys guys about to float
away fermenting my beverages you don't
shake up milk before you drink it I
don't drink milk player what if you have
a bowl of cereal player who do I think I
am [__] did this show turn into you
don't shake milk nah my bad dog over
slap the [__] out of you that's improv
for you baby
baby hey you're real cool cat could be a
jive turkey
Toby what do you got uh all right this
is Rees uh are you garbage if you get
your haircut at a mall yes I've done it
but yeah it's trash well documented on
the program complete trash unless you're
talking
again 88 89 90 when the mall was banging
I still all my cousins and aunts used to
get their haircut at uh listen I don't
know I've met a handful of these people
I don't think they're like the indicator
of cool if your ants were getting their
they were back then your ants what your
ants weren't cool and ID single work
they were single working ladies ho they
were getting their haircut at a mall
these broads like the Ramones single
working ladies what are you talking
about that's not cool I'm not saying
they're B you're to take it as I'm
saying they're bad I'm not saying
anything bad about them I just don't
think they well how come they always had
day we're always going out on dates and
stuff like that because they're
whes I'm sorry how dare you yeah no
they're I mean I wonder do you think
they were getting so much action cuz
they had good looking hair my mom was a
single working lady she wasn't getting
her haircut at [__] she probably went
to a barber shop trim her mustache
keeping it night you two wen't matching
she went to Mary Paul's and they weren't
exactly going out with Tom C
yeah actually my cousin did go out with
Tom celic his roommate's old neighbor
when he wasn't filming Magnum PI yeah he
was a ballet he parked his car uh yeah
Mary Paula she get a Mary Paul I'm going
to Mary Paul's get my haircut yeah Mary
Paul Mary Paul had a little I'm going to
get my hair done hair done had a little
uh turn the garage part of the garage
into a nice uh nice Salon you never get
your haircut at a aeda or any other hair
cutting school where you get someone
real green in aeda though they they're
like proper shops in the in the city
yeah that that's a that's a line of
products they have a school I only know
it as a line of products yeah it's fancy
ones at that it's not very yes you're
wrong no a lot of Hot Topic managers
looking for a lateral move running
through there they might at the school
yeah yeah that's what he's talking about
I remember I almost went to a dental
school to get a tooth pulled or
something like that
yikes Somebody went and was like don't
do it you sure about
this yeah that's uh that ain't great I D
I went to a place around here last week
or two weeks ago or whatever I never had
such unprofessional I like I'm not a guy
just what I just cut the hair in and out
this guy was going man I'm so tired I it
must have been on drugs or something
he's yawning he he went and made a
coffee and came back I'm sitting there
he got half my head cut he
God I just can't he's like doing this
and stuff pulling out the straight Razer
yeah I was like what the [__]
dude [__] do a bump and get on the
[__] straighten Arrow here and finish
the job there ain't that much hair hey
you want me to call my guy just
straightened out of here Focus you I
know Papa Ridin uh all right let's see
here this one's from Derek uh is a
garbage a cut through a shopping center
to avoid a traffic light no all the time
you really got to stick and move you got
to it's trashy yes it's trash remember
remember when I was younger my dad made
it seem like the feds would come and get
you if you did that man dude all right
we're cutting through the thing is there
any cops like they don't give a [__]
there was this one no through traffic
like there was like a heavy intersection
and as like you know over the years got
the line to get longer and longer so
there was this neighborhood that you
could cut through and we would be like I
think my dad had a number memorized like
oh we're going to one through3 Mocking
Bird lane or whatever if he got ped got
the SWAT team came down on and we would
be looking to see if a car followed us
the whole or like you know one time we
did drive by a cop or I heard there was
a cop posted up there last week don't
cut through nolles Avenue or whatever
was dude it was like you thought we were
[__] doing a bank job why did they
why were they so afraid of that I don't
know man that and turning the light on
in the car the dome light it was just
anxiety I I don't I don't what a it $88
ticket or hey I'm sorry I didn't realize
I'm in a rush my kid [__] his pants I'd
[__] my pants on if my dad was like I'm
sorry my my son let's be honest you
probably i' play you're probably halfway
there yeah you know what I mean like
like there's some sort of like hey my
bad guy let me off with a warning I'll
never do it again dad my dad used to cut
through this uh gas station and he would
go so far as to pull in and pull into a
stall for like a minute turn the car off
and back on and then go that's wild come
on late for practice here let's go no
one's tailing you I think my dad got
pulled over maybe once in the entire
time that I was a kid I don't I can't
remember uh uh might have had two Tree
in him back in the early days too oh
yeah I mean that's that leav a Christmas
party or work every day it was more of a
guideline than a law sure back then I
mean I I've yeah I've been documented
saying I got my don't drink and drive
conversation while having beers in a
pickup truck
with an adult male figure yeah who may
or may not have been my father sure uh
allegedly different time yeah it was the
[__] you know it was only 2018 it
wasn't that long ago yeah they were
arresting people for cutting through gas
stations the Johnny law was all the long
arm of the wall was all over me yeah
that light when that light came on it
was freak out city that was on for two
seconds dude meanwhile me and my brother
are fist fighting I'm jumping over the
back seats into the back of the Jeep
you'll kill everybody on the turnpike if
you turn that light on mhm I do get it
everybody I do get it I'm also the guy
to be like if I'm looking for like if
I'm like looking for a house like and
I'll I'll turn the radio on you got to
concentrate it is a distraction I'll
give you that I don't like loud music
like that unless I'm in the zone you're
a little too crazy with the loud music
sometimes on the road play your rap
songs your I got to stay up you guys
also all [__] sleep I'm the I'm the
you guys there's a lot of times where
it's just me with [__] five Souls of
if I just hit the pen and you're
cranking it and you don't really know
where you're going and this and that I
get a little antsy in my pant oh I'm
sorry that that's the experience for you
to do your drugs and hang I'm just
sharing yeah me too maybe stop doing
your smoking your chba plus your classic
rock mixtape's got to get upgraded I
can't listen to any more Credence on the
road for the true roof well I'm sorry
they not put any more music out it's
classic rock I know what do you want
from
me it's a goddamn algorithm that pulls
it together it's not like I'm playing my
best of the blue oyster Coke could right
another hit huh what the [__] blaming me
for no more classic rock songs coming
out and also we end up in the car for 48
hours together you're going to hear some
repeats what do you want from me
breaking my
Stones fair enough um all right let's
see here this one's from uh Marshall
from Cleveland what up dog yo is it
garbage if your stepdad was your
baseball coach growing up I still had to
run laps when he brought me to practice
late and he would also hit me with
[__] from time to time uh never had
the dad as a coach dad always coached my
older brother for the most not always
but like he was you where the talent was
in the family sure uh getting beamed by
your stepdad is crazy he just like a
little chin music next time you'll take
the trash out toughen you up a little
bit though I like that sure I mean yeah
I remember that dude I my dad had such a
bad experience coaching my brother's
team that it was like I'm never there
was these two [__] big brothers that
were bad okay and they would like talk
[__] they were like they were like dudes
they're bad kids bad kids I'm sure I I I
ended up seeing them again later in life
they you know whatever but they were
just like they were too bit real they
were like my size now they were like 11
they were like [__] you like they're
doing whatever they want and man my dad
went to I like almost fought them in the
Dugout one time he's like yo [__] this I
ain't coming back like you know you're
quit midseason yeah or like something it
was like I'm not doing this cuz I'm
going to end up fighting these kids or
their parents like this is [__] we're
not doing this I'm not sitting here
taking [__] from a 10-year-old the one
kid got a tattoo for Christ's sake I
know it's like D I can hit him so I
think it was like once it got to me he
like yeah I'm [__] I'm not doing that
I love those dads that were coaches sure
remember I saw uh Mr corus one time
they're talking this was like 87 sounds
like you saw him getting a wedgie Mr
corus he was real estate King in our
area man he was awesome and uh he he
could rent you any studio apartment you
need dude he talking we're talking the
BBS in the 80s big business as those
neighborhoods were all being built he
killed it but man he had these like
short shorts on one time we had this old
wooden bench and you know those pinching
bugs that you find pinch behind the
cushion of outdoor furniture which makes
me I always look they might as well be
scorpions dude I don't trust those
chairs and and those that type of
furniture at all a wicker they're like a
beetle roach a wi but a wicker Shay
lounge with um yeah those pincher bugs
signs of what is it earwigs are they're
called get me out of those I just know
them as pincher I mean look at that
that's a dinosaur that and a daddy long
leg forget about it but man one of those
latched on to his inner thigh yikes it
look like he got shot scared the [__]
out of us jez oh those things can be the
creeps ah look at that thing yeah those
are things are prehistoric man that's in
the back too do they pinch or is it just
uh yeah they
pinch okay get you uh yeah I don't know
I don't think I've ever been long legs
don't though they don't mess with you I
think they're I think they're actually
like one of those things that are like
good cuz they eat the other bugs or
whatever I don't know whoever's doing
the pr for spiders of over the past
decade has really earned their cash cuz
every like don't touch a spiders spiders
are great they eat the spiders the bugs
in the house get no I can't kill him
though what spiders I can't unless it's
a hairy scary one and he's in he's in
the perimeter but if he's up in the
corner I'll let him go you're nuts you
enter my my my my my Abode you're
getting got I don't care what you are
only roaches and mosquito and I catch
one of those things on the wrong night
they'll get an earful one of those
pinching bugs got a real talking to man
I'll go after his family send him to his
room you kidding me in there he ain't
happy will get you uh okay this one's
from Christopher $10 shareholder is it
garbage if garlic bread in your
household consisted of toasted white
bread with butter and garlic powder on
it I mean I my stepdad would do that and
I thought he was a michell and star Chef
just just the idea of I can do this at
home I was like what the I'm like we
just got garlic bread now that's crazy
dude you take an old hamburger bun throw
a little butter and some garlic salt on
there put that in the oven let's go dude
he would put it in like a like a bowl
and whip it up to get like whip that up
like that and maybe like a chai or
something a parsley or
oregano and then if we were if we had a
French or like Italian loaf of bread
that we were doing like pasta or
whatever and like they stopped and
grabbed that on the way home on those or
many a time it was white just white
bread but man you couldn't tell me [__]
looking in the toaster till the butter
melts perfectly cuz if it gets too
liquidy you're [__] you got make a
little Sky
sandwich soaking up some [__] dude
that would a side that on the side of a
a bowl of butter noodles somebody was
defending you the other day with your
sugar bread wasn't your what's your
sugar bread recipe grilled cheese with
powdered sugar oh no I thought you did
plain sugar bread no dude I was that
sounds like something you made up didn't
you I thought you made up a sugarbread
plane
please I'm not one of them Hy toyy boys
I thought you said your mom did uh like
like homemade cinnamon toast like butter
sugar and cinnamon no I don't believe so
somebody was defending that uh I saw an
Instagram story post of someone doing
that I think it was butter and sugar as
a sandwich yeah and they went off to the
mine for their shift yeah yeah we never
did any of that forgot that's what it
was powdered sugar and grilled cheese
weird that was yeah that's too much my
God you know what made you feel like a
millionaire the first time you had it I
probably didn't have it till I was 25
twice baked potato God I love a twice
baked potato love a TB every bit every
potato should be baked twice yeah what
are we doing here get it scoop it out
Whip It Up put it back in the frozen
ones just had that flavor and they were
like they were puffed they were they
were like out of the bag they had the
texture to them like the little little
swirl M dude I'm not even [__] around
a six-pack of those sat in my freezer
for about 38 years
dude they those things were so freezer
bured and like every time I was so
disappointed I'd open up the [__]
freezer and see them things and have to
lift them up see what's under they just
stayed in there then they got moved to
the outside fridge I'm like toots give
it up we're not going to eat these
things the thing I'm talking about
though made you feel like a a
millionaire is the garlic bread from the
freezer aisle that came prepackaged in
the tin foil that you threw it in the
oven buddy never had that so good
unbelievable they sell them fresh now
yeah you get them fresh they're pretty
good there would be they'd be like in
the bakery aisle right like the hand
rolled tin foil thing I think my stepmom
used to do those but they were a little
too like uh they had like kind of minced
garlic on the top and as a little little
too spicy oh baby you might as well been
from Spain or something with that lose
the hob and arrows honey yeah what the
[__] dude that was nuts need a bowl of
kicks to cool this off I remember the
first time too my wife gave me a ginger
shot man I thought I thought I ate a
firecracker dude thought this broad
poison me what I just thought it was
going to be like it was like ginger and
like just one of those like little
Shooters and she's like oh this is good
for whatever I was like all right almost
hit her I was like that's n you got to
give me a [__] heads up I love those
things it's the closest I get to Whiskey
these days sure I get it now I just
didn't know I was expecting a sweet
treating I was I was cruel I was wrong
thought to be like sorbet yeah I was
wrong dude nice bow of Sherby um the
Texas toast reain Supreme though as a
kid dud that my stepmom shout out to or
ex- stepmom introduced me to that there
is and we've we've discussed this but
Texas toast in there is
a window of taking that out of the oven
that is
about2 Nan seconds long where it is
perfect where the outside is crusty and
then there's a heaviness in the center
in the Soggy where it like sinks down
uhhuh but I so then they got they got to
like a not great but then when they sat
and got room temperature or cold oh my
God make a sandwich dude I would eat a
[__] I'd eat four bowls of [__]
pasta three pieces of that go upstairs
watch WWF come back downstairs and that
that I would still be in the basket like
sitting grab a heater
oh I'd get a WWA iced tea and one of
them maybe two of them on a plate
[__] take them up to my room for no
no
time hold all my calls the fat kid in I
used to just eat a lot of everything I
dude I I I I remember should have put
the kai but listen I ain't blaming my
parents they just didn't know I was
unsupervised know they we shouldn't be
in the half a sauce pan of reron at 9:00
at night clean the goddamn kitchen up
honey they were telling us to have 6 to
11 servings of carbs a day I had to get
I I needed something to power me through
my video game session you need brain
food I know you half a loaf of bread
they told me that yeah dude have thrown
that out I remember the first I'm not
even joking the first time I was up to
Poconos my family and a bunch of other
families like my dad's ex business
partners or whatever all got got in
together on a Pocono like a cabin uh and
you would I I think we only ever used it
twice before like everything dissolved
but I I remember have biting and sipping
for my first time ever and it was a can
I was six probably holy [__] dude it was
a can of Coke and a and uh and gold
pepperd Farm goldfish and all the kids
were playing upstairs like some like
board game I was too young to play so I
was just watching but I remember you
were mapping the future I would run down
every like I was addicted to it I would
run I would do and like I remember
eating goldfish and standing at the
fridge crushing and being like this is
too much this is too many goldfish and
this is too many sodas so good and I I I
look back on that and was like and I
literally go that was the turning point
for me feeling that Sal cheesy sugary
sweet effervescent cold and I the can
was half open I would to some swe and
sips and then put it in in the fridge
and run back up to see what was going on
and then run back down and I I think
that is the moment I became a fat ass
I'm not even lying it was that moment I
went I'll never be the same sure this is
the life for me I chose a life of CME
the bite and sip the bite and sip yeah I
probably crushed a bag of [__]
goldfish at six years old yeah the dad
everybody's drinking at the table I'm
floating between the adults and the
older kids mine was similar but it was
cheit it was cheit and I think like a
screaming cold Coke or Pepsi nothing's
better yeah nothing's better than cheap
Wheat Thins bag a thing of Wheat Thins
and a and a bite and sip on Triscuits
are better get out of here with that
you're nuts it's Tris Triscuits stink
for a bite and sip no you think are you
sure you have them right the the the
shredded wheat
ones that's a Triscuit you're you're
thinking wheat THS Wheat Thin the
cracker I'm thinking of Triscuits you're
a Triscuit guy they're the best bite and
sip there's so much more of absor the
the weins don't absorb the liquid what
are you a divorc lady wein that's an NPR
cracker dude what are you talking about
no they have flavors man get the rosem
those for your Avon Google the Rosemary
tusin blend it's to die for yeah pairs
well with PBS dork what are you talking
about no that and your vibrator and your
sock
drawer
man Triscuits are better they have a
deeper taste and the the Wheat Thins are
like plastic mm-
solid all right uh on on the same line
of on the same vein they have a touch of
sea salt one or something the other item
New Age [__] they've been having that
for [__] 20 years sea salt sea salt
wasn't invented until like three years
ago what are you talking about you're
wrong the other like frozen item that I
always saw that never got was the 10 the
10f foil like container of the pre-made
cinnamon rolls oh no never yeah it was
always pillsberry huh Frozen yeah we
never never did cinnamon rolls like that
we did we did the never I never said you
did it what the [__] yeah we did I'm
like I I never had dinner with you jerk
off what the [__] this guy's made about
Triscuits call my mom a liar uh yeah we
never did those we would do the
Pillsbury round like the the croissant
not the croissants like the regular
johnes yeah they were burnt every night
too but pop them out throw the icing on
it icing was always a nightmare no never
did that um all right let's see here uh
this one's just funny uh this is from
Josh you ever been served papers no no I
kind of want I don't want to but it
would be movies make that job look so
cool oh yeah you feel like a spa you got
a you got a trunk full of costumes is
that how it goes down have you ever been
served papers no but that's the rule I
think if you say you know somebody
that's been served papers oh I'm sure
most of my I've been served
papers but they just came to my house
and dropped something off yeah they get
that guy if they can't find you like if
you're like doctor
it's a bush no it was it was for an
accident that I got in years ago that
accident that I got in in Jersey yeah
the one that you haven't stopped
bringing up every week for I don't know
14 years at this yeah that guy Ser get
over it you want to talk about my dad
hitting the panic button when that guy
came to the door yeah you're all nuts
woo I mean you can't I started bleaching
my hair on the you try to sue someone in
my family they tell you to get in line
you better hope there's something left
by the time the [__] the [__]
vultures are done with me uh these bones
have been pick
clean yeah no uh I haven't but I think
they only resort to that if you're
refusing service like if the guy comes
you know to like serve you and you're
like not answering the door that's when
they get you know time to break out the
clown shoes yeah that's when they get
tricky and and throw you know thr would
have been a great summer job doing that
probably get your ass beat once or twice
tow truck driving they don't that's not
like [__] there a tow TR that's like
hey can you fight type [__] there's a
tow truck driver on Instagram that's
real nice with it he sneaks right in and
he's got cameras set up everywhere
there's one guy there's one guy I don't
like uh he shows up with like a woman
it's like a and like he's just like
tries to fight the guy it's like looking
for trouble yeah it's like dude this you
know the cameras are on you're miked up
you're just doing this for con just and
the guy's having a bad day just take his
car and get the [__] out of here mhm but
hey you get got you get got you know
what I mean no no papers other than that
well I guess so yeah I I tell you I've
been getting a couple of I don't know if
I told I think got a couple of calls
from a lawyer in Long Island City what
I've gotten two or three they don't
leave a message but that's the number I
don't know there's nothing they could
get me for there's nothing I have
outstanding I did I did get in a car
accident with that taxi cab before that
was 3 years ago at this point when I
that was the that was the last for the
Montego one that was when I got M uh I
have no idea what you're talking about I
I was living down the shore Toby get out
of things I was living it was in the
early days of the pot I was living down
the shore and I was driving up to record
I don't remember this at all okay uh and
I I smashed a a taxi cam allegedly for
comedy purposes I'm telling the story
they would leave a message holdo Mr R
that was [__] four years ago I never
heard that I mean that's the only thing
it could be got to to that
call yeah no I don't that's fully [__]
the Ryan don't answer calls from
attorneys yeah they they usually get me
eventually cuz I get in there I want to
know what it is oh yeah no I can pull my
head on the pillow and go whatever it is
you ain't getting it pick rocks buddy I
got some company in Chicago Harris and
Harris keep reaching out to me for some
like lab court bill for like 80 bucks or
something no that's going to be a no for
me
dog and for that reason I'm out yeah uh
keep it moving yeah no I don't I don't I
don't answer any calls that any numbers
that I don't know well now it's pretty
tough for business purposes that stuff
has got to gone downhill so bad well no
it's just Robo so it's all I know but no
but they used to be able to get you
they'd be able to get you on the phone
they'd be able to scare you missed the
court date they'd be able to scare you
yeah but I'm saying it was one guy
calling now it's just a computer that
just makes a thousand calls a second
nobody picks up those calls people are
picking up those calls people are
picking up those calls yeah it's also
like they used to have to have a room
full of 400 guys calling people now it's
like there's two guys then they have ai
that does it now they can just hear you
and you're like ah yeah I I I'll give
you 50 bucks and they go okay hit the
secured line for [__] credit card
transformation everything that a robot
pretended to be a
surgeon pretend to be a
surgeon you've been served you've been
served all right this one's from Mike
hav't had one read wils bear homie shout
out to you it is the
WB the original birthplace of hle that's
right is it garbage to take your car to
the car wash instead of cleaning off the
snow I live about 30 seconds from a car
wash instead of cleaning the snow off
the car I started driving to the car
wash and washing it off that's pretty
sweet I guess it's one of the the hand
that's smart talk about come you come
out clean when everybody's all salted up
wouldn't that ice up
or they have a little that water have a
little chemical in it I don't know it's
got to have a little got have something
that doesn't freeze salt or something in
it yeah that's a good idea I would do
that all the time I my I got to get mine
down air I haven't W dude I haven't
mine's bad dude I haven't washed this
car in probably like a year mhm you're
not in it as much either though no but
but that salt eats
away and I hate the the impression of
the wipers and it's it's like frosted on
the I got bad wipers I got to take care
terrible M are bad I want to get that
rainx stuff that stuff's great I don't
even need the wipers that's one of those
things too I'm never going to remember
to replaced them but I was driving to
New York the other day and it was
[__] uh raining on the new car yeah
the wipers s it was a used car really
got they replac the wipers huh that's
where their margins are that I get you
yeah that thing might be a lemon I'm not
sure aftermarket double
wipers neon green uh all right let's see
this one let's do one more now we got to
roll this is a little more of a debate
this one's from Good Old Jr garbage or
Garbage or genius I order an Uber to my
home which is the furthest along the
route of two other co-workers who just
simply get out at the red lights and
walk the couple blocks to their home
instead of programming and paying for
the additional
stop youpr they let you get away with
that well if you're at a red light and
you just what they what are they going
to say get in the car you can just be
like actually I'm going to hop out here
he says I've had I have not I not I've
not had many complaints about this
behavior that means some but my Uber
rating has taken a noticeable dip since
doing this sure so three guys get in the
car with one destination the driver
thinks oh these three guys are going to
this one they're all going to 34 Street
and then at 23rd Street someone hops out
it's like two guys hop out at two
different stops sh that's bad that's
pushing it yeah if every if somebody's
like actually you know what change of
plans I'm going to hop out here I'd go I
would have some sort of story line too
like you're cutting through the parking
lot ah just [__] my I got to hop out and
a fake a fake I have to throw up will
get you out of a lot sure that's not bad
yeah I yeah I I don't see how they can
get up I because they're they're not
going anywhere else like by the rule
book They're going to 34 Street they're
not making any other turn someone's just
getting out of the car it doesn't matter
if there's one person in that car or
four people in that car but that's two
more stops that you'd be getting you'd
be making more money but he's not making
any
stops I understand like he's just he's
going in his eyes in his eyes he's
losing money oh you cheap bastard you
don't want me to drop you off so you're
just you know whatever I mean I I yeah
sure I get that but I'm saying like also
at the end of the day you're not super
wrong to be doing that if you do that in
a cab that's fine say he does this from
work every day you know I guess a good
amount man he says he does it with
co-workers it's pretty smart I don't
know what to tell you I don't know how
small of a town he lives in but that's
New York oh he Liv in oh what yeah [__]
it dude it's Lawless yeah come on it's
say something it's every man for himself
I thought he lived in a civilization no
no no in the front lines of this thing
yeah yeah I'd ride behind it on a
skateboard you kidding me do some
skitching Marty McFly style uh but we
got to wrap it up gang gang tell you
this all the time we love you to death
grab some tickets for the through the
roof tour we're very excited about it
it's going to be sick see us at Town
Hall see us at the Wilbur see in any
City that we're in we love you very much
and we'll see you next week peace peace